hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will learn the critical
differences between Microsoft Excel and
Microsoft powerbi that said if these are
the type of videos you'd like to watch
then hit that like And subscribe buttons
and the bell icon to get notified just
for a quick info if you want to upscale
yourself master data science and data
analytics skills and land your dream job
or grow your career then you must
explore simply learns SP of various data
science and data analytics programs
simply learn offers various
certifications and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
Caltech Purdue IIT conour and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge with work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced Excel python
machine learning data visualization
generative Ai and over a dozen others
that's not all you will also get the
opportunity to work with multiple
projects learn from from industry
experts working in Top Tire data and
product companies and academicians from
top universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a data science or data
analytics role or as a fresher or moved
onto a higher paying job and profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the print comment
and description box below to find a data
science and data analytics program that
fits your experience and areas of
Interest now without further delay let's
get started Excel and PBI are both
powerful tools for data analysis but
they serve different purposes and
different testing features here are top
10 differences between Excel and powerbi
starting with the first one data
visualization and business intelligence
Excel primarily a spreadsheet tool with
basic charting and visualization
capabilities powerbi designed
specifically for business intelligence
and data visualization providing more
advanced and Interactive
visualizations second difference is data
modeling and relationships Excel
supports basic data modeling but
creating and managing relationships
between tables can be more manual and
less intuitive on the other hand powerbi
it offers a robust data modeling
environment with easy to create
relationships between tables making it
more suitable for complex data
models the third difference between the
both is data import and transformation
Excel data import and transformation are
possible but can be more manual and less
scalable for large data sets now PBI PBI
has advanced capabilities for data
import transformation and cleaning
through Power query providing a more
scalable and automated approach fourth
difference is data refresh and scheduled
updates Excel data refresh is more
manual and may require manual
intervention powerp powerp allows for
scheduled data refreshes ensuring that
reports and dashboards are automatically
updated with the latest data fifth
difference between the both is sharing
and collaboration sharing can be done
through file attachments but
collaboration features are limited in
Excel powerbi built for sharing and
collaboration with cloud-based sharing
options and the ability to publish
reports to the power service for broader
access the sixth feature is RO level
security Excel it has limited support
for RO level security on the other hand
for powerp it provides robust Ro level
security features allowing you to
control access to data at a granual
level based on user roles now the
seventh difference between the both is
integration with external data sources
Excel Excel can connect to various data
sources but may require additional steps
for complex Integrations next is PBI PBI
offers seamless integration with a wide
range of external data sources including
databases cloud services and online
services now the E difference is custom
visuals and Marketplace Excel
visualizations are somewhat limited and
there is no centralized Marketplace for
additional visuals on the other hand we
have PBI PBI has a Marketplace for
custom visuals allowing users to access
and integrate a wide range of additional
visualizations created by the community
now the nth difference between the both
is data storytelling Excel has limited
capabilities for creating interactive
and dynamic data stories on the other
hand powerbi it includes features for
creating compiling data stores with
interactive elements making it easier to
communicate insights now the last
difference between the both is
scalability Excel while suitable for
smaller data set it may struggle with
handling large and complex data
sets on the other hand power Pi is
engineered for scalability making it
more efficient in handling large volumes
of data and providing better performance
in scenarios involving big
data in summary while Excel is a
versatile tool for General data analysis
and Reporting powerbi is specialized for
business intelligence offering more
advanced features for data modeling
visual I ization and collaboration the
choice between them depends on the
specific needs of your analysis and
Reporting tasks now let's discuss the
pros and cons of excel advantages or
Pros Excel is user friendly and has a
userfriendly interface as well Excel is
Excel has a familiar and userfriendly
interface making it accessible to users
with varying levels of expertise most
people are already familiar with basic
spreadsheet operations second Advantage
is versatility Exel is a versati for a
wide range of tasks including data
analysis Financial modeling budgeting
and Model Management and project
management budgeting and project
management it supports various functions
and features to accommodate different
needs third one is formula and function
capabilities Excel offers a robot set of
formulas and functions that allow users
to perform complex calculations and
Analysis users can create custom
formulas and automate calculations fifth
advantages data visualization ation
Excel provides basic charting and
graphing capabilities allowing users to
create visual representations of data
this helps in conveying information more
efficiently and effectively and making
data driven decisions fifth one is as of
data access and entry Excel makes it
easy to enter organize and manipulate
data users can quickly input data into
cells creating tables and use features
like data validation to ensure data
accuracy now let us discuss the cons or
disadvantages of excel starting with
limited data size and performance Excel
can struggle with large data sets or
complex calculations performance May
degrade and the software may become slow
when handling extensive data leading to
limitations and scalability manual data
updates is the second one data updates
and refreshes are often manual processes
in Excel this can lead to errors and
outdated information especially in
situations where data changes frequently
third disadvantage is lack of
centralized data storage Excel files are
typically stored on local machines which
can lead to Version Control issues
there's a risk of working with outdated
versions of files and it can be
challenging to maintain a centralized
and up to- dat data
set fourth one is limited collaboration
features while Excel allows for sharing
of files real-time collaboration is
limited multiple users can't really
easily work on the same file
simultaneously which can hinder
collaboration in team settings now the
fifth one is security concerns Excel
files May lack robot security features
and sensitive information can be
vulnerable if proper precautions are not
taken access control and data encryption
are not as advanced as in specialized
business intelligence tools like BBI and
tab now let us discuss the important
advantages and disadvantages or pros and
cons of powerbi starting with advantages
first one is Advanced Data
visualizations Pap Pi excels in data
visualization offering a wide range of
sophisticated charts graphs and
interactive dashboards second one is
robust data modeling powerbi provides a
powerful data modeling environment with
features like relationships calculated
columns and measures third one is
seamless data integration powerbi
seamlessly integrates with a variety of
data sources including databases cloud
services and online platforms fourth one
is realtime data refresh powerbi allows
for scheduled data refreshes ensuring
that reports and dashboards are
automatically updated with the latest
data fifth one is collaboration and
sharing powerbi is designed for
collaboration and it can integrate with
cloud-based sharing options now let us
discuss the disadvantages of PBI
starting with learning curve PBI has a
steeper learning curve compared to basic
spreadsheet tools like Excel second one
is cost while powerbi offers a free
version more advanced features and
capabilities are available only in
powerbi Pro which comes with a
subscription cost third one is
dependency on internet connection
powerbi relies on internet connection
especially for sharing and accessing
reports through the powerbi service
model now fourth one is limited offline
functionality while powerp allows users
to download and work with reports
offline to some extent certain features
and interactivity may be limited when
disconnected from internet now the last
disadvantage which is about security and
compliance concerns organizations
handling sensitive data may have
specific security and compliance
requirements while powerb provide
security features organizations need to
carefully configure and manage access to
ensure compliance with their policies
now with that we have come to an end of
the session on powerbi versus Excel if
you have any queries to regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require any resources that we used
in this session like PB then you can let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts we'll be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here